when rates are as high as they are in
Wales today everything we do has an
impact on the virus and every contact we
have counts
I must be clear
if rates continue to rise rather than
fall the cabinet will have to consider
raising the alert level and
reintroducing some further restrictions
at the next review
now of course none of us wanted to see
that happen none of us want to see your
return to restrictions in the economy or
in our own lives and that is why over
the coming three weeks we will
strengthen six measures from the
requirement to a face coverings to
changing the guidance on self-isolation
we're changing that Guidance the South
isolation guidance to reflect the latest
evidence about household transmission
you are more likely to catch coronavirus
if you are living with someone who
already has it
self-isolation helps to break the change
of transmission and so prevent the virus
spreading quickly through the community
people who are fully vaccinated or Age 5
to 17 will now need to self-isolate
until they have a negative PCR test if
they live in the same household as
someone who has covered 19. this is
similar to the system in place in
Scotland where cases peaked already and
are now lower than they are here
of course if you test positive you must
self-isolate for 10 days and
self-isolation support payments of 750
pounds a week continue to be available
for people who are eligible
over the next three weeks we will also
extend the covid pass
we've made coveted passes compulsory in
nightclubs and in larger indoor and
outdoor events just a fortnight ago and
the implementation so far has gone very
successfully
while cases are so high we will extend
their use to theaters Cinemas and
concert halls in two weeks time these
are ticketed indoor venues where large
numbers of people come together are in
close contact with one another and are
there for extended periods of time
and as I said earlier if cases of
coronavirus continue to rise rather than
fall we will have to consider expanding
the use of the covid pass further
including into the hospitality sector
let me say something uh briefly next
about schools I want to thank of course
the education sector for everything that
has been done to reduce disruption and
support students in what has been a
challenging start to the Autumn term
we already have an infection control
framework in place that allows schools
to make decisions about the measures
they need to put in place to protect
staff and learners
further to support head teachers we will
publish a toolkit next week to help
schools with higher numbers of cases to
introduce more protections more quickly
and we will redouble our efforts to
encourage staff and secondary school
students to take up the offer of twice
weekly lateral flow tests to help to
keep them safe regular testing together
with the protective measures will help
to keep coronavirus out of our schools
now when coronavirus infections are this
high in the community working from home
is a really important measure to protect
People's Health and reduce opportunities
for the virus to spread in workplaces
the Welsh government is urging all
employers to help more people to work
from home over the next three weeks the
Welsh government will lead by example
and reduce the number of people coming
into our offices
we're also meeting retailers to
encourage them to do more to raise
awareness of the legal requirement to
wear face coverings in shops
and finally in terms of these defenses
to vaccination vaccination is our best
defense against the virus and it's never
too late to become vaccinated here in
Wales
providing a booster vaccine to everyone
over 50 all Frontline Health and Care
staff everyone with an underlying health
condition and all care home residents
will help to reduce infections
hospitalizations and deaths
it's a month since we started the Autumn
booster campaign in Wales and already
more than 400 000 people have had that
vital booster injection
by Monday we will have offered the
booster to all eligible care home
residents
over the half term we focused on
vaccinating 12 to 15 year olds with many
centers offering walk-in appointments
more than 40 percent of 12 to 15 year
olds have already been vaccinated and
all will have been offered vaccination
by next Monday
so the next three weeks are vital if we
are to keep Wales safe and Wales at
alert level zero
cases of coronavirus are too high across
Wales and we have to work together once
again to bring them under control
we've done it before and we can do it
this time again together we can keep
well safe and we can keep whales open